hold on tear gas being fired and to
disperse the crowd mike what's going on
well more tear gas has come out and what
we're seeing that preceded the tear gas
is these uh fences that were installed
today uh the
some of the crowd had those fences and
they were
shaking that and uh at risk i guess of
of of uh doing some damage to the fence
itself now the white smoke i
think that's tear gas because the tear
gas has been deployed a couple of times
already
what we don't see over here in the
northwest side of the police uh
headquarters is that the police are
advancing now with a big cloud of gas
coming
we see this every time the crowd will
protesters will scatter for a while
i'm probably going to start coughing
here in a second because the gas is
coming my way but the protesters scatter
for a bit
and then they'll reform the wind is
blowing in this direction
so as a gas comes this way there's a
group that is just
behind that cloud of gas and they're not
moving
and yeah that's tear gas all right if we
turn around
you can see i'm looking at you is that
your gas impacting
is that tear gas impacting you are you
having a hard time seeing
yeah yeah i'm having a hard time seeing
and breathing right now
but you can see now those
officers we were showing you before that
came outside of the fence
they are still out there on the street
what is not there with them anymore
are all the demonstrators who were going
through this game that we see the back
and forth the antagonizing the shouting
the throwing of objects they're out on
the street
and presumably they're just going to
come marching in this northwest
direction
and we'll see what goes on with the rest
of the crowd we'll take a look back in
this northwest direction
and they did not it would turn around uh
this way you get the camera shot
they did not effectively clear all
if you if you need a break mike we
understand if you need to break this
tell us
i got it we've been through gas a few
times but you still have uh
i ball parked that about 200
demonstrators off in that direction
and they are upwind of where the gas was
deployed so they didn't scatter
we had a lot of the demonstrators down
in this direction who have scattered
and uh mike why don't we give you mike
we're gonna give you a break and uh
we'll go back to mike in just a moment
uh and get his take